[Música]
muy buenas a todas ya todos
y bueno voy a hablar del poder de la
tecnología
entonces me acuerdo cuando empecé a
preparar esta charla que muchas veces me
pasa que empiezo las cosas por el final
y así fue pero luego cuando empecé como
a practicar la ensayar la
bueno yo soy un poco impaciente y un
poquito impulsivo también con lo cual no
podía estar esperando toda la charla
para dar el titular con lo cual pues voy
a empezar por el final y os lo voy a
decir y ya luego construimos seguimos
vale
entonces el poder de la tecnología cuál
es el poder de la tecnología
la tecnología no es nada la tecnología
es un instrumento de quién es el poder
quien lo tiene nosotros
nosotros si lo tenemos lo que pasa y
tenemos mucho lo que pasa que esto
asusta un poco porque el poder conlleva
responsabilidad y no es lo mismo cuando
nos pasa algo echar balones fuera o
responsabilizar a la tecnología a la
sociedad a la pareja a los políticos en
fin a las cosas ajenas a nosotros que
mirarnos nosotros
mirarnos nosotros da un poco de miedo
y como dice la psicología en la gestión
de las emociones
el miedo todas las esto de las emociones
positivas y negativas no existen todas
las emociones son positivas si no nos
habríamos conservado a lo largo de toda
la evolución darwiniana se encargó de
explicar esto así que si tenemos el
miedo es porque el miedo es evolutivo y
el miedo evolutivo nos ayuda a
prepararnos
y de ahí ese mí y de eso va un poquito
esto que vamos a ver cuáles son o cuáles
pueden ser algunas consecuencias de las
tecnologías pero no van a depender de
ellas van a depender de nosotros van a
depender de cómo las utilicemos y van a
depender de cómo la gestionamos y esa es
un poquito me gustaba mucho la palabra
conciencia con la que han presentado
esta charla y eso es un poco la idea de
esto como fomentar la conciencia sobre
el uso que hacemos de los dispositivos
y con esa conciencia puedes poder elegir
bueno otra cosa que quería plantar aquí
desde el principio es este debate que
bueno ya teniendo en cuenta esto un poco
se puede responder que es este debate
sobre si las tecnologías son buenas o
malas
si son peligrosas o no bueno pues nada
los que somos buenos o malos somos
nosotros o al menos los que podemos
serlo o los que los que podemos ser
funcionales o disfuncionales somos
nosotros
pero bueno yo creo que sí es cierto que
la tecnología las tecnologías son una
herramienta son un instrumento no están
llevamos hablando toda la mañana sobre
eso y son un instrumento poderoso
entonces vamos a ver algunas de las
algunas de las aplicaciones nunca mejor
dicho que tiene este instrumento y ver
un poquito cuáles pueden ser las
consecuencias en función de que en
función de nosotros de nuestra libertad
y de nuestra gestión
bueno lo primero es podríamos hablar del
acceso a la información no yo creo que
estamos de acuerdo en que las
tecnologías nos facilitan acceder a la
información a un golpe de clic podemos
tener información sobre prácticamente
cualquier tema
sin embargo cuál es el precio de esto
el precio es qué
una cosa es la información y otra cosa
es el conocimiento y el conocimiento hay
una parte del conocimiento que tiene que
ver con como si fuese una cocción a
fuego lento
qué es lo que nos lleva a la sabiduría y
eso tiene que ver con profundizar eso
tiene que ver con parar eso tiene que
ver con investigar sobre un tema
bueno otra cosa que tiene esta
herramienta este instrumento de las
tecnologías por ejemplo es como todo es
como fácil y rápido no es como las
tecnologías nos abren la puerta a muchas
cosas eso es cierto
y todo es como rápido fácil si quiero
algo me conecta al ordenador o saco el
móvil y lo tengo todo ahí como en la
mano no
no es necesario un proceso para
conseguir algo que quiero
si quiero jugar a algo si quiero ponerme
en un videojuego solamente tengo que
enchufarlo o tengo que comprarlo y hoy
en día bueno ya sabemos cómo funciona
esto de la economía que no hay dinero
para
no hay dinero para necesidades básicas
pero si hay dinero para los dispositivos
con lo cual también es fácil tenerlos
cuál es el precio de esto el precio es
que qué pasa cuando en la vida nos
encontramos con que cuando queremos algo
no lo podemos tener ya
qué pasa en la vida cuando
por ejemplo si queremos ejercer una
profesión o queremos trabajar de algo no
lo podemos hacer ya y estamos yo creo
que todos y todas de acuerdo en que no
es fácil no sino que supone un esfuerzo
supone un trabajo y supone también una
tolerancia a la frustración poder
manejar la frustración poder estar poder
afrontar situaciones que son difíciles y
sostenerlas y continuar y de ahí a la
voluntad
otra cosa de este instrumento las
relaciones o las tecnologías nos
permiten relacionarnos y es fenomenal
insisto en este debate de si son buenas
o malas si tienen beneficios o
perjuicios ambas cosas
si queremos hablar con alguien
fácilmente podemos hacerlo
pero qué es lo que pasa con las
relaciones en una característica que
define las relaciones saludables y es el
concepto de intimidad en qué consiste la
intimidad la intimidad es un contacto
entre dos o más personas donde hay
a ver cómo lo digo
donde hay
es como
un respeto hacia las diferencias
donde hay una relación más allá de que
seamos parecidos o distintos
donde la comunicación se transmite a
través de la presencia y ahí hay algo
que se comparte
que por ejemplo nunca podrá reflejarlo
un emoticono
[Música]
y luego también podríamos hablar de cómo
nos relacionamos en las redes sociales
podemos ver perfiles estaría bien
seleccionar algunos aleatoriamente y
verlos pero bueno yo creo que todas y
todos nos podemos imaginar un poquito
normalmente en las redes sociales o en
los perfiles estamos de acuerdo en que
mostramos como nuestra mejor cara un
poquito
como nuestras experiencias positivas
como cuando nos lo pasamos bien como
cuando estamos ahí como que todo nos va
maravillosamente
esto pasa mucho en las relaciones y es
que la primera parte de la relación
siempre es como lo mejor de esto todos
tenemos experiencia no conocemos a
alguien maravilloso y luego pasa un
tiempo y vaya me engañó no nos engañamos
nosotros que muchas veces vemos en el
otro lo que necesitamos lo que queremos
ver y ahí es donde está nuestro poder en
qué consiste la intimidad la intimidad
es ver nuestra mejor cara y la peor cara
y relacionarnos desde ahí también
incluir eso en el vínculo y eso es lo
que hace un vínculo profundo sincero
íntimo
y luego también otra cosa que tiene esta
herramienta este instrumento poderoso de
las nuevas tecnologías es por ejemplo el
tema de
la relación que guardan con el
sentimiento de valía con la autoestima
estamos de acuerdo en que las redes
sociales o las tecnologías nos brindan
la posibilidad de recibir como un
sentimiento de yo valgo o soy importante
por ejemplo tenemos una publicación
subimos una foto y pues cuanto la
extiende
o subimos un vídeo y cuántas
visualizaciones o cuántos suscriptores o
cuántos followers y en función del
número en función de la cantidad se pone
el valor
cuál es el precio de esto
quizás ya nos lo estamos imaginando y
y es que la autoestima como dice la
palabra auto estima tiene que ver
conmigo y es que pasa con la valoración
o la apreciación que yo hago sobre mis
propias cosas dónde queda eso en la
tecnología
porque la tecnología de alguna forma nos
nos invita a un mundo que está afuera
pero qué pasa con el mundo y el universo
que está adentro
qué pasa con él me gustó a mí me
encantaría que pusieran esa opción
también me gustó lo que pongo
bueno otra cosa de las tecnologías por
ejemplo es el ser lo que queramos esto
es una gran ventaja está nuestro ego a
nuestro ideal le encanta que es yo
quiero ser algo y fácilmente con la
tecnología con algún filtro o con algún
filtro que otro con alguna cosita puedo
ser un poco como lo que lo que le gusta
mi ideal se entiende esto más o menos no
es como que gracias a la tecnología se
podría decir o en la tecnología podemos
ser lo que queramos pero que cuál es el
precio que pasa en la realidad con lo
que somos
qué pasa con nuestro yo real
el yo ideal en las redes sociales suele
corresponderse bastante lo que mostramos
con nuestro ideal pero en nuestro yo
real donde quedan
dónde está y cómo está
[Música]
y a veces bueno yo soy psicólogo de
profesión y me lo tiro mucho para el
terreno para el propio terreno y es que
a veces hay como un abandono de sí como
un abandono de
de nosotros mismos por una exposición a
los demás y eso tiene un precio y es que
luego no nos sentimos llenos y siempre
hay un vacío que nunca conseguimos
llenar
la tecnología es un universo infinito
sin límites sin límites sin embargo hay
algo como que no le basta como que
siempre necesita más y ese es otro
riesgo y es porque lo que lo que
necesitamos no está fuera
está en otro lugar está adentro una
maestra me dijo una vez
esta frase de la salida es hacia adentro
y la tecnología está afuera que está
fenomenal porque hay un equilibrio entre
la fuera y el adentro pero corremos el
riesgo de estar muy afuera y perdernos
perder no perdernos del adentro
lo último que me gustaría decir sobre
estas cualidades de la tecnología es que
la tecnología nos
favorece o nos invita o nos posibilita
el hecho de desconectar el hecho de
fíjate que se habla de conectar y a mí
me parece que en la tecnología
desconectamos más que conectamos pero
bueno esto es una apreciación personal
pero sí que nos favorece cuando estamos
ahí como agobiados con algo preocupados
con algo la tecnología nos nos ofrece la
posibilidad un poquito como de descansar
un poquito la cabeza la mente y
efectivamente está demostrado que un
poquito de tiempo y ayuda a descansar el
cerebro
sin embargo si nos pasamos de un tiempo
el cerebro se debilita
y luego aquí hay como otra consecuencia
que insisto la idea es poner conciencia
en esto no crear miedo o crear alarma no
tiene sentido si crear conciencia y
conocimiento sobre lo que estamos
haciendo y cuando sabemos lo que estamos
haciendo tenemos más posibilidades de
elegir otras cosas
cuál es el tema de recurrir a las
tecnologías para desconectarnos o para
cuando tenemos un problema un poquito
como para estar bueno relajarnos un poco
el precio que pagamos es que qué pasa
con ese problema
qué pasa con lo que nos pasa qué pasa
con esa tensión
insisto un poquito puede ayudar pero si
recurrimos demasiado
los temas pendientes que tenemos cada
uno con nosotros mismos y con nuestra
vida no se van a resolver afuera no nos
lo va a resolver nadie ni nada ni ningún
aparato ni ninguna persona ni ninguna
pareja ni ninguna sustancia el tema
pendiente está ahí
y lo que también me gustaría
transmitiros es que ese tema pendiente
se puede resolver y lo podemos resolver
y ese es nuestro poder es en nuestro
poder
es cierto que nuestro poder no tiene
límites pero la realidad sí
y hay entre el infinito y el finito hay
como una danza como un baile
así que bailemos
[Aplausos]